you just think it's a tick tock like
you're watching it you don't even know
you're you're watching an ad and that's
the secret don't make it like an ad off
the bat like hey buy my stuff that
doesn't work you have to do content
disguised as an ad I'm gonna show you
the right way to do it you're gonna take
a lot of the same principles with just
making your normal reels and tick tocks
first off you gotta have a good hook in
the beginning right then the next thing
is value I'm giving them some kind of
value and each reel I do is always that
same framework hook
value and then I go to the close where
it's like hey if you want to do this too
if you want to learn how I got through
it and how other students have DM me
this keyword I have so many of these
I've created probably like 50 to them
and I literally just run the same ones
over and over again this video alone I
think the first time we ran it got like
a hundred thousand views to get a
hundred thousand views for free
organically you know think about how
much revenue that video made